it's gonna pop back like nobody has ever
seen before that's my opinion but I
think it'll pop back like nobody's ever
seen before please questions
specifically how many new hospital
facilities could the Army Corps of
Engineers build and also what specific
measures are you taking to try to
increase the number of ventilators in
this life we've ordered massive numbers
of ventilators we have by any normal
standards we have a lot of respirators
ventilators we have tremendous amounts
of equipment but compared to what we're
talking about here this has never been
done before and yesterday I gave the
governor is the right to go order
directly if they want if they feel they
can do it faster then going through the
federal government now we've knocked out
all of the bureaucracy it's very direct
but it's still always faster to order
directly and I gave them that was
totally misinterpreted by the New York
Times on purpose unfortunately but the
the but it's very important yes ma'am I
could amplify yeah please a president
directed us to work with the Department
of Defense there's two ways that DoD can
be helpful in terms of expanding medical
capacity I know the governor of New York
has asked us to look at the Army Corps
of engineer which could perhaps renovate
existing buildings but the president
also has us inventorying what you all
would understand as field hospitals or
mass hospitals that can be deployed very
quickly we spoke with a Governor Inslee
yesterday in Washington State
we have resources in that part of the
country that we could move and as
governors make these requests we will
process them bring them to the president
but there are two different lanes that
VOD can provide in addition to many
medical supplies to augment our national
reserves and the president has tasked us
to to evaluate and make available and to
consider every every request from
governor's for either field hospitals
expanding facilities or the Army Corps
of engineer that could retrofit existing
buildings
the Army Corps is very prepared to do as
we say and we're looking at where it's
going but and they do call them mash
hospitals but the field hospitals go
very quickly they
we have them we have all of this
equipment in stock and we're looking at
different sites and a few different
locations and we're not going to need
them in West Virginia where so far I
guess they have none
still none still none West Virginia no
Big Jim the governor's you must be doing
a good job
that's what's reported issue or is that
that they have no cases well that's all
that I saw jigna is the only one that
has no case testing issue so obviously
that's being treated differently than in
New York or or a California different
parts of California I do say this so the
the Army Corps of Engineers is ready
willing and able we have to give them
the go-ahead if we find that it's going
to be necessary we think we can have
quite a few units up very rapidly I'm
gonna work with Governor Cuomo I'm going
to work with a number of the governor's
governor Newsom has been very generous
and has in his words and I'm being
generous to him too because we're all
working together very well and and I
think a lot a lot of very positive
things have taken place we're talking to
California about different sites but we
can we can have a lot of units up fairly
quickly if we think we need them I think
what I'll do is I might ask Seema to say
a few words on the telehealth and that
we can get back to this please oh dear
not Sima liar Thank You mr. president
and as the president announced earlier
we are doing a dramatic expansion of
what's known as telehealth for our 62
million Medicare beneficiaries who are
amongst the most vulnerable to the
corona virus and we're acting in accord
with the appropriations bill that was
signed on March 6 as well as the
president's emergency declaration last
week and this action is a part of our
broader effort to ensure that government
requirements rules and regulations don't
get in the way of patient care during an
emergency and today's announcement
builds on the significant progress of
the president has already made over the
past three years around telehealth
services and while we have allowed for
virtual check-ins full telehealth
benefits have been restricted to those
living in rural areas established
patients and just for those brief visit
but no longer Medicare beneficiaries
across the nation no matter where they
live will now be able to receive a wide
range of services via telehealth without
ever having to leave home and these
services can also be provided in a
variety of settings including nursing
homes hospital outpatient departments
and more and thanks to the leadership of
HHS will also be temporarily relaxing
certain HIPAA requirements so that
doctors can provide telehealth with
their own phones and we'll be using
enforcement discretion when it comes to
collecting co-pays so that cost won't be
a barrier this is a part of our larger
efforts around mitigation and as we are
encouraging Americans to stay home
whenever possible we don't want our
Medicare policies getting in the way and
so consider the implications of this
perhaps an elderly patient with diabetes
needs routine checkup and this has
nothing to do with the coronavirus and
so with our new telehealth benefits this
person who's not really who's at risk
for the corona virus doesn't have to
venture outside their home they can talk
to their doctor via Skype and they don't
have to risk exposure to the virus and
they can receive that care from the
safety of their own home it could be
another Medicare recipient who's
experiencing mild flu-like symptoms and
instead of leaving the house and sitting
in a waiting room full of other
vulnerable people they can also receive
advice from their doctor from their home
and this shift is very important for
clinicians and providers who over the
coming weeks will face considerable
strain on their time and resources and
now Medicare patients who don't
absolutely need to come in to an office
won't have to and this allows the
healthcare system to prioritize for care
for those that are more that have more
needs or in dire need and preserves
protective equipment as well State
Medicaid agencies can also provide
telehealth services without federal
approval and so we're asking all states
to make this available as well and we've
also asked private insurance companies
to expand their telehealth benefits and
make it clear to their providers and
their members what they cover
as our nation seeks to balance the twin
imperatives of getting Americans the
care that they need during this outbreak
and limiting the spread of the virus the
impact of this historic action simply
cannot be overstated
in an emergency those on the front lines
shouldn't have to worry about federal
rules and red tape hamstringing them
when they need flexibility above all
else we're doing everything in our power
to make sure that that doesn't happen I
also just want to briefly mention that
because of the president's emergency
declaration we do have the ability to
provide a lot of Medicaid waivers and
Florida was the first state to be
approved we were able to do that in a
matter of days where people are still
partying on there do your citizens go
for instructions on how to do the tillow
they should call their doctor's office
and their doctor's office can tell them
how to do that I'm also you know there
may be some of our Medicare members that
may not have access to equipment so
we're asking family members but to help
with this but also respecting the
requirements around social distancing
and if any of those family members or
neighbors have symptoms they should
obviously stay be posting members or so
that's correct
if you post and they can also call our
1-800 Medicare number and they can also
get information those phone lines are
open well thank you very much as we
talked about earlier this week the
commercial system is rapidly advancing
in the testing capabilities as of today
our public health laboratories meaning
the CDC and the public health labs have
reported out 30 1878 tests so almost
32,000 tests the clinical laboratories
the association of clinical laboratories
have reported out to about 27,000 tests
and most importantly of those 27,000
during the cumulative period of time
8200 of them were yesterday this is
showing the dramatic ramp is the high
throughput comes in we don't have the
numbers this morning from the American
Hospital Association which
means all the individual Hospital
laboratories we will have that up coming
in the next day or so and then
ambassador birx will have this whole
process a fixed under with the
legislation that everything will roll up
into a common reporting probably by the
end of next week in terms of our drive
through laboratories again these are
blossoming all over the country by
individual states the ones that we are
heavily involved in and really pushing
equipment to we expect over the next few
days to begin setting up 47 of these in
approximately 12 states the material is
already palletized and being shipped to
the locations most cities have the
specific locations some do not but it's
still going to a central receiving and
we know that we'll be deploying at least
140 commissioned Corps officers about
half of the sites have reported their
requirements about 140 officers will be
going we expect that to go up so this is
going on the way we expected we did a
trial site yesterday with a full mobile
unit for driving through with full PPE
we had a lot of kinks in the system as
you can expect that's why we do a test
before we go out into the field don't
expect these to be a hundred percent
perfect the moment they come they're
going to be adapted to the state in a
local situation but we're very confident
that these will add testing to the
already very robust health care system
and commercial system Thank You mr.
president
particularly all right this has never
been done before and it's a great
roadmap for future should we have
something like this in the future I hope
we don't but it's never been done before
and they've done an incredible job again
we're working with the states and
relying on the states we have to because
they they have its point of sale its
point of sight and were in I think just
about every instance getting along
really well with the with the states if
I could
dr. Burks if you could say a couple of
words please
Thank You mr. president so I think what
you've been hearing from us is to find
solutions that are high-quality and
sustainable based on the front line
workers and governor's request and I
those come in on the governor's call
we've been immediately responsive to
those and that's the the level of red
tape and bureaucracy that we have
removed I think that point about
sustainability and quality is very
important because as the president says
we're creating a roadmap for a different
level of functionality for future
pandemics our flu pandemic preparedness
plan was a plan now we're seeing where
we have to revise where we have to
create new avenues of research and new
avenues of work to really ensure that
the need of the American people can be
reached
we were adamant about having a high
quality test based on our commercial
vendors over the next few months you
will begin to see that other tests that
were utilized around the world we're not
of the same quality resulting in false
positives and potentially false
negatives these tests were studied and
studied by the FDA to really ensure that
they are that level of quality and we've
given the states the permission to
ensure that same level of quality now I
wanted to say one minute on the testing
testing should not be used as an
assessment of your risk we are asking
every single American no matter what
your generation from Z and up to X and
Millennials in between to really ensure
that you're following these guidelines
we hear every night of people who are
not in work moving that time into bars
and other areas of large gatherings if
we continue with that process we will
fail in containing this virus yes so
every single generation has a role to
play Gary we're asking our older
generation to stay in their homes
and we're asking the younger generations
to support them in social contacting
through videos and other Skype type
functions or just the simple telephone
we're asking the younger generations to
stop going out in public places
bars and restaurants and spreading a
symptomatic virus onto countertops
you're gonna need to say it daily
grocery stores and grocery carts I heard
an innovation last night and this
morning again on the news I really want
to applaud the private sector who are
now creating senior only shopping times
I think that's extraordinary I think
that shows what America brings and I
think other countries will learn from us
about how to really protect seniors in
this type of way I'm hoping that carries
through to next year when we have our
flu epidemic where we can really have a
very different prototype for a file of
the mountain or utility that we have
during flu that we never talked about
anywhere from 15,000 to 45,000
individuals are lost every year if we
learn how to do this well and sustain
some of those chord changes we can
change the way respiratory viruses not
only for this but the future affect
Americans it's a big thing a little too
optimistic for where we are right now
maybe a question on the clinical data so
we've had now early 5,000 people test
positive we've had 90 deaths or so when
are we going to know the data of who
those people are who has been infected
what the ages are what the pre-existing
conditions are how serious it was both
for those who have been tested positive
but also those who have died
well you're singing my sheet of music
I'm very data oriented so thank you for
bringing up this issue of data I really
want to applaud HHS we had a discussion
about this several days ago they've made
calls in to Seattle and California to
really understand that and also
importantly to understand how many of
their patients needed ventilators how
many of them needed oxygen support how
many of them needed and what they needed
could we predict early someone who was
going to have a more difficult course
these are all the questions we're asking
right and answering right now we did get
an early report back from Santa Clara
and Seattle we're digesting it we just
got it this morning we're looking at
that carefully because we think that
road
it's very important to other communities
we have not discussed this with New York
yet we do know from other countries and
that all is available online that
profile you can see that mortality and
ER 30 is extraordinarily low the
mortality across the board outside of
Wuhan is now settling somewhere around
0.7 but that should not be reassuring
because it's much higher in people with
pre-existing medical conditions even if
young and people that are older with
pre-existing medical conditions and so
we still want every American focused on
doing what they can do today to change
the course of this pandemic it's making
that data public so we will all know
we're committed not only to making it
public but to have a website that
everyone can see in real-time
there you are signaling a much more
aggressive posture toward containment
mitigation now in many states have been
very aggressive but there is a small
number of states yes that has not have
not issued public guidance yes is it
important for the success of the effort
that 100% of the states be forward
leaning on this yes if so mr. president
what would be your message to those
states that have not okay so that's why
the vice president and the president
yesterday issued those critical
guidelines as I said this morning on Fox
& Friends you can look at them as a
guidelines you can look at them
requirements and you can look at on as
the president asking every American in
every state to follow those that's why
we put them out at the federal level we
wanted to make sure every American knew
what they could do today to change the
course of this epidemic
I think it's empowering I think it says
all of us have a social responsibility
to each other and that's why we believe
that every mayor and every governor
should be instituting these guidelines
that came from House and the President
of the United States
stateside know exactly who you're
talking to we've been very tough in
there thank you I hope the testing
you've been telling us for days now that
millions of tests have been sent down so
why have fewer than 60,000 people
actually been tested I think you will
see different numbers this week you
heard just at 8,000 remember all of
these tests the high speed tests were
approved last Friday last Friday night
and last Thursday night I think if I
could talk to thermo Fisher and the
other groups that have these platforms
out there do not rely on a pull
technology push out those tests because
we can only make them available groups
have to order them so I we've been
talking to thermo Fisher one of the key
platforms to push out tests based on
need and not wait for orders we that's a
great question it's both know part of it
is getting the test out right now I
think the Admiral and others are working
on getting that the issues related to
getting the tests conducted I'll tell
you more about that take time he is
working on innovative solutions that are
creative and sustainable that will be a
game changer in testing but we don't
have the data yet this is a critical
comparator can you do it yourself
can you actually sample yourself these
these are the kinds of things we're
working on right now and he's getting
the data for us the states are actually
doing a lot of us the Governors and the
states are doing a lot of it with even
our tests thank you can you give us a
sense of how long these tough new
restrictions will need to be in place
until we start to see possibly August
virus going down
so can you speak to this study that as
many as 2.2 million people in the United
States could die if their work this type
of action by the government taken I
think you know models are models and
they're based on input and they're based
on infectiousness without any controls I
can tell you we've never seen that level
of infections that modeled up to that
2.2 million and mortality so we are
looking at that we are having a
particularly model meeting tomorrow I
think that's really going to be
important model time I've dealt with a
lot of modelers in my time they're
wonderful people but they all have their
favorite in release and they all have
their favorite integration functions so
we're evaluating all of those so we can
integrate and create the best model for
the United States based on the best data
and that first set of recommendations
you saw were based on what we could do
today to prevent anything that looks
like that if I could just say one other
thing to the hospitals and dentists out
there things that don't need to be done
over the next two weeks don't get it
done if you're a person with an electric
cert elective surgery you don't want to
go into a hospital right now
there's identity protection there's a
lot of people doing a lot of other
things to save people's lives so let's
all be responsible and cancel things
that we can cancel to really free up
hospital beds in space and then let's do
everything that we can to ensure that we
don't need the ventilators because we've
protected the people who would have
needed to Trump smirking looking forward
to that model business or the operations
like for example limiting travel within
the unite
it's possible it's possible we'll see
how it goes a lot of it's been great
cooperation with the local governments
states we'll see how it goes it's going
it's going right now pretty well yeah do
you need to invoke the defense
production Act to get more of those
medical supplies it's different well
we're able to do that if we have to
right now we haven't had to but it's
certainly ready if I want it we can do
it very quickly we've studied it very
closely over two weeks ago actually
closely and strong will make that
decision pretty quickly if we need it we
hope we don't need it it's a big step
you know when you say the stage in
particular three states need some help
and some states you know have two people
three people no people in the case of
again West Virginia so we're looking
nobody looked closely we've taken it
apart 15 different ways it's a very
difficult thing to do it's a very big
step and if we need that step we'll take
it okay first question a lot of people
have got travelled to places that are
considered hot spots you have Caribbean
Mexico that sort of thing over the next
few weeks would you recommend that they
follow through those plans I would just
say enjoy your home stay don't travel
anything we we have to get this problem
fixed and he's right back into business
real really quick will open up our
country will open up our society the
world will hopefully open up we see
areas of the world that are that haven't
done well and we see areas that are
doing very well and I would put us in
the category of doing very well for a
country so big I think that I would
recommend that they just enjoy their
living room go ahead please
once you say to people who are not
heating these guidelines from the White
House and then also have a question on
asymptomatic doctor I'm not happy with
those people if they're not but you know
those people are being shouted down by
other people they know they're being too
many ARMs almost like self policing they
should be that people went in there are
a couple of instances I guess probably
more than a couple where people are not
happy when they see others doing what
they're not supposed to be doing we have
to get rid of this we have to win this
war
and ideally quickly quickly there's the
longer it takes it's not a good
situation I like the attitude even
talking about the economy I'm talking
about the lives of a lot of people and
yeah give us a sense Mike we've got to
all work in progress what President
Trump has made clear to industries
around the country is that we're gonna
do whatever it takes now we understand
this is an extraordinary moment in the
life of our nation it's the reason why
the president brought in leaders at the
financial sector airline industry he'll
meet with all new additional industry
leaders today in tourism and hospitality
but he has tasked the Secretary of the
Treasury to work with members of
Congress in both parties to make sure
that we construct the kind of economic
support that will allow those industries
to weather the period of the coronavirus
and then to come back stronger than ever
before we've had such incredible I don't
know it's almost the word spirit is the
best way it's like a spirit the banks
have come in and the banks are doing
things that they would have never done
because they want the money extensions
and lots of things that they wouldn't
have done they want the bailout ways
with regard to the insurance companies I
mean for them to be doing what they're
doing you know all about the co-pays
they would have never done that and they
did it they were in my office they I
would say the 11 biggest in this country
I guess probably the 11 biggest of the
world the big ones all the big
and they they did things on copay that
nobody would be doing that they wouldn't
have done in a million years but they're
doing it there's a great spirit going on
right now in the country so you want to
yes please dr. pouchy
dr. pouchy you said you like being
accused of overreacting because that is
an indication we may be doing things
necessary to beat this bend the curve
how long do you think it will take for
you to be confident that yes we're
bending the curve or no or not you know
I can't give you a firm number on that
because the dynamics of outbreaks in
some respects are predictable
historically they do this and that we
don't know because this is really
unprecedented I mean of all the
outbreaks that I've been involved with
over the last at least 36 years and then
going historically back we've never had
a situation where the mobilisation of
all the different components travel
restrictions internal the containment
mitigation financial assistance public
health assistant testing so we don't
really know but the one thing I do know
I do know that if you look at models
with all of their Vice Institutes of
models is that when you have input into
the kinds of mitigations and things that
we're doing we're gonna see a hump
instead of a peak I would be really
surprised if all the things that we're
doing and and this is really a
comprehensive approach I hope is where I
struck as I was listening to everyone
make their their presentations that you
know I'm a scientist I'm a health person
and I'm a physician who sees patients so
I look at it from one particular
standpoint but what I'm being impressed
by is that this is really a
comprehensive thing that has multiple
components different all of them got to
succeed if we're gonna get to that
endpoint that I've described multiple
times from this podium so I hope that if
everyone does their job we're gonna be
able to give you a number and say you
know we've seen that inflection and
we're coming
I would hesitate to do it now to be
honest with you
yeah if what we're doing now is having
an effect we would know that in 10 days
I want to be misleading I just want to
say one other thing because I heard dr.
Berg say it and I think we need to say
it over and over again when I was young
a long time ago I felt that I was
invulnerable the way I think many of us
feel were invulnerable and when we're
asking the young people to help us with
this mitigation strategy by staying out
of the bars staying out of the
restaurants really trying to distance
yourself don't get the attitude well I'm
young I'm invulnerable you are well in
some respects you're certainly less
vulnerable than I am however what you
might inadvertently do and I know you
don't want to do that you don't want to
put your loved ones at risk particularly
the ones who are elderly and the ones
who have compromised conditions we can't
do this without the young people
cooperating please cooperate with us now
yes smartest and
but there is an early a new study of
China found that the vast majority of
cases 86% weren't untested patients with
mild to no symptoms so what does that
say about the impact of testing and does
it mean that testing should actually go
beyond this equation yes you know that
question keeps coming up and I'm not
gonna evade the question but I want to
make a point we tend to think that we're
not gonna be able to mitigate or contain
without testing they complement each
other in some respects but they're
separate channels even if we had no
testing we should be doing what we're
doing now the question you're asking so
I won't evade is specifically would it
be important outside of a doctor patient
coming in together of knowing what's out
there what might be under the radar
screen the answer to your question is
yes so let me tell you what the CDC is
doing right now they're going out there
and part of their program is to get a
feel for what is there that wasn't
initially thought to be corona virus
that was thought to be something else
yes when you do that you're also gonna
get a feel of what the penetrance is in
society so we are heading with the high
throughput things that you've been
hearing about to get an answer to your
question you need you know it's possible
I mean I know the governor has been
really doing a really good job of trying
to stay ahead of this 45 days is not
unreasonable yeah I have to be careful
when you get a number you own the number
and then if the number doesn't come out
you're in trouble and that's the reason
why from our standpoint from the federal
government we're talking about a range
so within that range I mean it isn't
like you want to be correct for the sake
of being correct but you don't want to
be Wed to something and then have to
back off
Oh what is it when is the soonest that
we'll know that these new guidelines are
actually bending the curve 10 to 12 days
and is there a point of time where you
you know in the next couple of weeks
where you'll be able to tell the
president more draconian measures are
needed well okay so what's happening I
mean if you look as a metaphor it's kind
of like a race against the virus if left
to its own devices will do this and us
trying to somehow blunt that now you
could see the virus going up and up and
your effect your work what you're trying
to do may actually be having an effect
but you may not see it because it'll
still be going up and as you're trying
to implement your your interference with
the virus you may not realize that you
were actually interfering in let's say
wait a minute it's still going up what's
going on you've done nothing but you
don't know whether it would do this
versus that so the answer to your
question it probably would be several
weeks and maybe longer before we know
whether we're having an effect it may be
at the end of the day we'll see a curve
that would have been way way up but I
wouldn't like put us to task every few
days well wait a minute it's going up is
it working or not that would be really
misleading if we do that
he's the smartest guy on the stage
nearly 80 years old people what is your
recommendation for people of Alabama
people across all of the country as far
as the guidelines that were announced by
the okay so the one thing we don't want
to do is to get hung up on the
difference between 10 and 25 I think you
might agree with that when we give
guidelines they're only guidelines we
sit down we look at the data as dr.
Burke state are data-driven and we say
on different models 10 looks good if
someone wants to do 25 we're not gonna
fault them but if someone wants to come
to us and ask us what we think the best
is we stand by the numbers it isn't
perfect it isn't precise math it's
assumptions and it's data that make you
get your decision yes of course but this
is the United States of America there's
a lot of free enterprise there people do
their own thing and quite frankly I
don't think there's a big deal
difference between 10 and 25 we got many
many more important things to worry
about than that difference supply chains
and then talking about preparedness for
the future yes
Larry Kudlow said that there was an idea
of floating around the administration to
cut taxes for companies who would be
bringing their supply chickens back to
the United States he said he
specifically liked immediate hundred
percent right osburgh no structure is
equipment but he said you hadn't
endorsed that yet what you were yelling
you're gonna have many ideas that's one
of them frankly and we're looking at
creating incentives for companies not
only that type of company but other
companies we're also looking to help
companies such as the airline industry
within the airline industry and we'll be
doing that we will be doing that this is
not their fault and they've been very
understanding actually and we're gonna
be helping them we will have a very
powerful airline industry and it'll
start up as soon as this is over we'll
we'll have those we'll have those planes
ready to go so we have to help them
during the short term was very important
yeah
have you taken a look at some of these
models such as the Imperial College
London model that kind of poses a very
difficult choice whether it's shutting
down society or overwhelming the
healthcare system is that something that
we look at every model we've relied on
the very talented people taking a person
look at the people many models behind me
and I will say that all of the people
that have done those models are all in
constant touch with dr. Burks and Tony
and everybody that you've been hearing
so much from over the last couple of
weeks we've looked at we've looked at
many different models and the model we
have is we want to save a lot of lives
we want to save a lot of lives if we get
too steep in that curve you're going to
lose a lot of lives perhaps
unnecessarily now we're gonna find out
if everything has a risk we're going to
see but if people do what we're telling
them to do what we're asking them to do
you're gonna see the saving of a lot of
lives now Boris in UK yesterday you saw
what happened it looked like they were
going a different way but that he went
away of similar I guess simpler I don't
know exactly but I would say we had a
conversation yesterday similar to what
we're doing perfect a lot of people seem
to think this is going to be we are we
are looking to save the maximum number
of lives everything else is going to
come back a lie
is never going to come back but
everything else our economy it's gonna
come roaring back you're gonna know
we're gonna know we're gonna all know
that day if somebody was asking about
the day when will you know when will you
know we're gonna know all of a sudden
we're gonna say wow that's looking good
that's looking good that's looking good
and we're gonna be on the other side of
the curve and that's a day that we look
forward to okay that made you decide
that yes now with the time to implement
these much more stringent social
distancing measures oh I don't think so
this is where we're going I really think
from the beginning this is where we were
going this is what we had in mind
we were just we're just going step by
step that was the next step the next
logical step has talked to foutch he
said and I think very importantly one of
the most important things when you write
the history of this was the fact that we
closed it down to China and Europe but a
particular China we closed it down to
China the source very very early very
very early far earlier than even the
great professionals wanted to do that
the bragging is that I think at the end
that's gonna be but that will have saved
a tremendous colleague
seems more somber yesterday yes timeline
did you see a projection some people
thought perhaps that two million
potentially that could die maybe
prompted part of that was there a shift
in tone I didn't think I mean I've seen
that where people actually liked it but
I didn't feel different I've always
known this is a this is a real this is a
pandemic
he's always for it was cool all you had
to do is look at other countries I think
now it's in almost a hundred and twenty
countries all over the world no I would
stop these verses there was no
difference yesterday from days before I
feel the tone is similar but some people
said it wasn't I don't think in terms of
recession I think in terms of getting it
out because when we're finished with the
virus we will win we will win and when
that victory takes place our economy is
going to go through the roof it is so
pent up it is so built up it is so ready
to go you know in an upward direction
there is an element of that I don't know
cinnamon talked about that tomorrow
tough enemy but we have to knock out all
of us that's all of us so I don't think
in terms of recession not recession it's
words we have to knock out this bum
that's all worried I actually think
we'll have an economy like we've never
had before it's all pent up I think the
question about about the actions that
the president authorized beginning in
January when he took the unprecedented
step of suspending all camp he always
calls tents up the brown it was to issue
travel advisories for portions of Italy
and South Korea and then to begin
screening all the passengers and the
efforts regarding suspending travel for
Europe and what went into effect at
midnight last night
adding the UK and Ireland to that have
all been informed by the experts that
are surrounding us what the president
has asked us to do from the very
beginning as doctor burse and doctor
felt you often say is let's follow the
data bring the president the best
options in response to what is actually
happening
the ground but but with regard to
yesterday's 15 day slow the spread plan
our team unanimously brought to the
president these very strong
recommendations for every American
because we truly believe we are at a
point in this epidemic in our country
when we can reduce the number of people
that actually are exposed to or contract
the coronavirus but will continue to
bring the best data the best evidence
and the best recommendations frankly of
the best health experts in the world
everybody has been that continue to make
everything's about the health of America
first
in other words reduce the number of
people that die that's what we're trying
to do and when you do the steep curve a
lot of people are gonna die a lot of
people you know the worst ever they say
1918 and I don't have to go into the
numbers but there were unbelievable
numbers hey and had they done what we
had now it would have been a very much
different story it would still be tragic
but it would have been a very much
different but that was that was the one
that people write about that was an
incredible that was a doozy
this one hope a matter hand emic like we
haven't seen but we have we have done
something that i hope hopefully we will
all have made the right moves we're all
in this together
I would rapping you and we want to see
fair press and and I tell you what it's
been generally speaking I think it's
been it's been a great thing to see it's
been very very the the getting along
with Democrats getting along with
Republicans for the Democrats themselves
there's been a lot of spirit there's
been a lot of things happening that I
haven't seen happen in the first almost
now three and a half years it's been
very nice to see that's one of the good
things but what really the good thing is
we have to knock it out we have to win
and we want to keep that slope as low as
possible because that's a lot of lives
in there
let's go back there somebody that then
you get mr. president this is not a huge
impact on China's economy as well have
you ever seen any indication from
officials there that they're going to
have trouble meeting the purchase
agreements part of the things one deal
particularly agricultural by well they
need our product very badly and no I
haven't received any one good
relationship with China I have not
received anything to that no we have a
signed agreement they're going to be
buying and they have been buying a lot
of product it's all grace earlier today
dr. Burks was talking about the
possibility of our hospital system being
overburdened overtaxed and she talked
about the options available to the
United States VA hospitals right
Department of Defense medical treatment
facilities and even hospital systems at
what point do you tap in to those
options well I'll know the point and by
speaking with Governor Cuomo and other
governors we're gonna know the points
it's gonna be different for New York
that it's gonna be from you know Iowa or
from Idaho or from West Virginia frankly
or for any you know it's it's different
New York he's got a big problem the
state of Washington as a big problem
California has some big problems
everyone's doing a good job but we're
gonna know when it will be and I believe
it'll be more spot that it will be it's
not gonna be the whole thing it's going
to be spots there are some hot spots
that are in trouble big trouble and
there are other areas that are in no
trouble at all they watch it on
television they don't know you know it's
just not affecting them and that's
they're lucky they're lucky but there
are areas of the country that don't have
much of a problem and some that don't
have any problem they're not gonna have
a problem with hospitals but some areas
like New York California of state of
Washington they're going to have some
difficulty and when we see that coming
we're going to be in there were already
making preparation for it right
Senator Marco Rubio of Florida your
trained adviser Peter Navarro have been
recommending an executive order that
would ensure that the raw materials for
pharmaceuticals and medical devices are
manufactured here in the United States
we were getting some indications last
week that you were close to signing this
executive order can you tell us what
looking at different things John I don't
want to say exactly right now China has
been sending us everything we need but
we're we're looking at some alternatives
yes we are looking for alternatives and
we have other places Ireland does a lot
of work for us you know that in that
world in the pharma world a very
tremendous producer and we are looking
to bring a lot more back home I mean
excuse me you know me for a long time
I've been talking about this for many
years long before I decided to run for
president I've been talking about this
and we have to be able to take care of
our country and that was one of the many
things on the list so we'll be talking
about it but we are we are discussing it
in Marco's very much involved and Peter
is very much and a lot of people are
involved and a lot of people feel that
way but we'll be discussing you said
Canada as opposed its borders
non-citizens
are you considering not other than
America the United States of course
are you considering closing the land
borders in the United States and also
you've disel Canada has not closer to
the United States so we're working very
closely with Canada and but they have
not closed it they have closed it to the
world but they have not closed it to the
United States but in the u.s. land
border I don't want to say that but we
are discussing things with Canada and
we're discussing things with Mexico
Canada quite honestly and again the
relationship is outstanding with both
outstanding we just signed our deal u.s.
MCA and beautiful relationship is very
strong
the others have criticized you for using
the phrase Chinese virus how do you
continue using that phrase well China
was putting out information which was
false that our military gave this to
them that was false and rather than
having an argument I said I have to call
it where it came from it did come from
China so I think it's a very accurate
term but no I didn't appreciate the fact
that China was saying that our military
gave it to them our military did not
give give it to anybody well they did it
then I got phrase crazy stigma no I
don't think so no I think saying that
our military gave it to them creates a
stigma please travel and tourism
executives today with specific help are
you going to offer to help they need
help
let's face it you know they go from
having record-breaking years this is the
third year of record-breaking year's
travel and tourism airlines everything
they were doing record numbers ordering
new planes building new hotels
everything was really hunky-dory and
then one day we hear about this rumour
in China and then we find out as China
that a rumor and then all of a sudden we
make a great decision to close it up
early it would be a whole different
world we a whole different world but we
make a decision to close it up to China
and all of a sudden tourism and and then
we close it up to Europe which you know
people never heard of this before I'm
not sure that that's ever been done I
know that when I made the decision to
close that to China people told me
that's never been done before what was a
great decision we make good decisions so
I'll tell you my best decision the
people behind me are total for us all
over the world they're respected dr.
Burks Anthony who's become wears it to
become a major television star got all
the right reasons now he's just so
professional so good the people that we
have working here had
in incredible and they're totally
respected the Admiral has been
incredible having to do with the testing
incredible and he's he's viewing this as
testing also for the future but building
a platform when we took over this
platform first thing the Admiral said
was this wasn't that designed for what
we're talking with everybody and
everything being so good it's shocking
we have any cases at all right dick you
don't think like this but we broke it
down and it's really gonna be incredible
system and it is now a great system I
just I just want to say these are
incredible people standing behind me
they're the most respected in the world
every country that you've mentioned
today so far has called them and they
call them all the time for advice
there's nobody better than work we have
[Music]
doing a good job we're very happy with
him mr. president
yesterday we were being told that the
payroll tax was gonna comprise the
lion's share of the fiscal stimulus
right we also had the markets fall quite
dramatically yesterday
and we did that and was it about the
better well did that inform your
decision what in what in what made you
make that change and when did you make
that oh I didn't make a change well look
at the payroll tax and we're looking at
various other forms of getting money to
people and the payroll tax is something
that I've always liked problem is it
does take a period of time you know
months before they really see something
and we don't really have months in terms
of people living you know a lot of these
you have you have people that work on
tips you have people in our it's a large
number of people it's a tremendous who
would think this right but and they do
nicely they work very hard but they work
on tips we have to take care of our
people who we don't want to have people
suffering during this period it wasn't
their fault that the this thing all of a
sudden was upon us so we're looking at
various we're also looking at payroll
tax you know it's possible it's also
possible we'll do a percentage of
payroll tax and then other things but
we'd like to be able to get money to
people you know we're very lucky our
country is doing so well we can do this
and we can do it easily but we have to
do it and I have to say Mitch McConnell
if you look at Mitch and Kevin and the
whole group and it's been it's been
incredible how they're reacting how
Congress is reacting how whether it's
the House or Senate how they're they're
moving and I'm talking about Democrats
and Republicans but we've had tremendous
leadership meetings and they want to see
it done right and they do want to go big
I think the only big is important I
don't think we want to go up there every
day with a different idea a different
concept don't worry about the airlines
let's do this one you have a big problem
with the cruise ship industry it's an
industry that was setting all sorts of
records two months ago that all of a
sudden there's nobody on the ships okay
so we have to help these these are great
and these are going to be taking care of
people and passengers and and for years
to come and paying tremendous taxes
tremendous taxes for years to come so we
have to make sure that this is done yes
mister
what you refer to just a short while ago
about politics of a near address to the
nation you said we have to put politics
aside stop the partisanship and unified
together this morning you criticize the
Democratic governor of Michigan
yesterday was the Democratic governor of
New York you've attacked Obama you
talked to be attacked by in fact every
day except one since that address
you've lashed out at a Democratic leader
are the example they only do that one I
have to respond
I watched her on television she said
something that was false and therefore I
did do that I'll continue to do that if
they're not gonna play fair because you
know they have the media on their side I
don't I just have me and if they're not
gonna play fair all gonna do that if
they are gonna play fair there's gonna
be nobody nobody better than Donald
Trump in terms of bipartisanship but if
if they're going to say things at her
false like the story that was written
yesterday a lot of people I don't know
somebody I think I know who but they
taped the conference call that I had
with the governor's it was a good call
it was fine I assume or somebody is
going to tape it perfect they handed it
to various people in one of it was the
New York Times and The New York Times
chose to write totally inaccurately
about it it was a disgraceful thing was
bad journalism but you know they do a
lot of bad journalism but we respond to
that and actually people get it people
get it no I wanted to be bipartisan and
nobody's gonna be better than me but
when they attack me or the people these
incredible people behind me I'm not
gonna let him get away with it I can't
do that
okay how about one or two more questions
go ahead please I would wrap
[Music]
after the national census well you can
do a national lockdown hopefully we're
not gonna need that we think of
everything I mean we have every idea
that you mentioned we've thought of and
you know it's a very big step that's a
step that I mean in one sense would work
it's a very big step it's something we
talked about but we haven't decided to
do that please mr. president would be
the determining factors for you to take
that action
it would have to get to a level I just
don't think it's gonna be an action that
we're gonna take I don't think I'll talk
but Anthony all of the people standing
behind me would get together in a room
plus some additional x' and we would
make a decision but I don't think that's
a step that we're going to be paying one
more question you didn't have one did
you come on government provide financial
assistance to Boeing and airplane
suppliers like GE we're looking at that
we're certainly looking at Boeing Boeing
got hit hard in many different ways
Boeing never had a problem for four
years they were they were an incredible
an Incred they were it was unthinkable
what happened with respect to bone
unthinkable probably I would consider it
the greatest company in the world prior
to a year ago now they get it done
fifteen different ways and they have
different management I've met the new
people the running Boeing I think it's
gonna be outstanding but yeah we have to
protect Boeing we have to absolutely
help help Boeing they were doing a job
they were getting it was coming along
well and then all of a sudden this hits
so obviously when the airlines aren't
doing well Boeing is not going to be
doing well so we'll be helping Boeing
yes mr. president before you leave on
what John was saying you called for
people to leave politics out of this Joe
Biden said the World Health Organization
offered testing kits that they had
available
to the United States and to give it to
us now we refused it we didn't want to
buy them PolitiFact says the WHI have
never made that offer can you tell us
well that's what I'm gonna let I'm gonna
let Tony answer that question or some
whoever's best at answering that but I
do have to say when you talk about
politics I watch the debate not too
exciting but what they said about me and
we've done a great job when you talk
about not not being bipartisan what they
said about me and if you look at swine
flu so I the whole thing and I guess it
was 2009 and what they did and the
mistakes they've made they were terrible
there were horrific mistakes 17,000
people died and I'll be honest
they shouldn't be criticizing because
we've done a fantastic job the only
thing we haven't done well is to get
good press we've done a fantastic job
but it hasn't been appreciated even the
the closing down of the borders which
had never been done and not only did we
close them but we closed them early the
press doesn't like writing about it well
so we've done a poor job when press
relationships and you know I guess I
don't know who to blame for that I don't
know maybe I can blame maybe I can blame
ourselves so that I will blame ourselves
but I think we've done a great job I
think we've done a poor job in terms of
press relationship but let me have
somebody answer your question okay I
tried to cover this in the answer when I
talked about quality of kids and our
quality analysis runs through the FDA so
all of these platforms we have asked
people to submit and we've asked States
to quality control so I mean this
anybody could submit their tests to us
we don't buy tests that haven't been
quality controlled and they show us the
data either show us the data upfront or
show us the data after they've been
running them it does quality testing for
our American people is paramount to us
it doesn't help to put out a test where
50% or 47% are false positives imagine
what that would mean to the American
people imagine their level of concern
and telling people that their false
positive we take this same approach to
HIV imagine telling someone they were
positive to HIV and they weren't so that
is our bottom line the customer the
American people first and so any of
these groups can submit their testing
kits through our regular hospital
processes interesting but without that
and without a plan we are not going to
accept tests that have not been studied
by us good answer I'm just gonna
emphasize a little bit more on that when
I became involved in the testing world I
called as senior officials at the WH o
as I could find to understand what the
situation was and as far as I can tell
from sources that should know no one
ever offered a test that we refused what
I heard - this was a this is a research
grade test right research grade test
that was never submit was not approved
not submitted to the FDA that was
supplied in tens of thousands of
quantities to a hundred countries in the
world okay so I think there's a lot that
people are saying about this this is
based on rumor and myth
nothing was offered that we refused it
was a research test that was not
approved and again there was a small
number that we have greatly surpassed in
a very short period of time so number
one nothing was offered number two it
was a bad test otherwise it was
wonderful listen thank you very much no
you made a mistake
oh my goodness
so there it is more more MORE daily
briefing seemingly at this point if you
are heading out and watching on youtube
please make sure to LIKE and subscribe
you'll be notified tonight when we go
live with election results I do
appreciate everybody who joined me but
please do it it really is important hit
that like button and do subscribe to the
channel before you leave then you will
be notified or you'll have the option of
being notified anytime we go live with
the coronavirus press conferences or
election streams or anything else thank
you on twitch we have surpassed 30,000
followers on twitch which I very much
appreciate as well let me say thank you
to some new members who signed up while
we were listening Tracy Morgan is new
member number two today s Huff is new
member number three today Aislin
Underwood is new member number four
today
Brad taishoff is new member number five
at join pakman.com want to say thanks to
Samuel Gonzales who is new member number
six and Chris Fitzpatrick is new member
number seven very very much appreciate
everybody's support continued support of
these streams let's answer some super
chats if you have one feel free to send
it in emmanuel ramirez varus's david
checkout came Iverson's channel video
about the virus thriving in certain
temperatures yeah we've got a bunch of
doctors we're interviewing about that
and i'm gonna i'm gonna focus in on what
they're saying z jump says destiny lost
this debate yet again seth Barham says
how many progressive policies do you
think will be implemented out of
necessity to address this seem social
programs or suddenly kosher yeah a lot
of the stuff i i don't know how we can
afford a lot of this crazy stuff that
we're doing which is of course necessary
Aerith sam says we can prevent the
spread by not inhaling tough to do Emma
Johnson says I live in Oklahoma our
governor said he's still gonna eat out B
crow says realized I haven't had a
notification from your channel in a bit
Aerith Sam says
wash takeout food before to prevent
infections
what like wash the food like if you get
like pad thai from a Thai restaurant you
just run the entire dish underwater
that's tough to do Kevin Shane says
minuchin in charge bonuses are safe yes
probably our retro path access spice
delight and Belmont is great Indian food
have never been to Belmont don't know
anything about it Walter sends a super
chat
Zachary Monroe says his Trump gonna use
a black sharpie sharpie to mark up those
models wouldn't be surprised
Jeremy comfort says Trump needs to shut
up
newah Matt says Trump takes the first
major word he hears China Canada etc and
keeps repeating it incessantly in a
monstrous word salad that has nothing to
do with the original questions reporters
are falling for it
yes they are hyped rain is happening on
Twitch let me say thanks to by Rachel
for the subscription political puppy
raff Kelly manias tranquilly Asst
encrypt TR croak will kill as well as
fried sicl4 subscribing over on Twitch
man those those usernames those
usernames are something else my friends
that is for sure
Costel eleska says be safe take
precautions if you have to stay inside
download the dysfunctional mariachi
album 308 DP you rock Thank You
Alexander Brault says I would love to
see a chart of stock markets with
Trump's koban 19 press conferences
highlighted yeah you know so today it
was kind of an up-and-down thing but
last week he did a press conference and
the stock market went way up yesterday's
it went way down
today's it went way down but recovered
about a third it's sort of all over the
map let me say thank you to a lien P and
grungy Dan also for their contributions
on twitch our divisions says it's a new
world order designed Cataclysm I would
avoid spreading conspiracies clever to
swear says he's letting out every brag
after yesterday yeah he is alley Mac
said I'm sorry oh god he's becoming
self-aware
Alonso Smith sends a super chat Robert
Pisani says stay safe David and everyone
else much-loved from Canada Baron
Steuben says thanks for the coverage
everybody drop a light yes remember like
and subscribe on youtube free hello
doesn't cost you anything Eric
Hendrickson says kind of disturbing they
don't refer to us as patients but as
customers yeah this is now the third
time that they've referred to people who
are sick and potentially sick as
customers tells you a lot Nano Brasi TV
says this is good stuff keep the good
work going
Hideyoshi Lacan says I'm enjoying
universal health care here in Canada
bomb-ass Dan Kass says how will voting
be effected will people turnout we will
know tonight okay so this was an
impromptu stream we do have a scheduled
stream 8 p.m. Eastern tonight join me
tonight it is going to be results from
Arizona Illinois and Florida Ohio has
canceled their primary tonight okay
that's it for now see you see everybody
in seven hours